[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 31 mai voici le programme de
ce soir j - 100 avant la Coupe du monde
de rugby à cette occasion les médailles
de l'événement ont été présentés
aujourd'hui mon conseil régional
d'Île-de-France elles sont conçues à
partir de téléphone recyclés toutes les
précisions avec nos journalistes qui
étaient présents sur place
coignières-la-verrière trappe et Les
Clayes-sous-Bois ces quatre villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines se retrouvent
en demi-finale pour le championnat inter
collège de match d'improvisation
théâtrale l'événement aura lieu vendredi
prochain à la Merise à Trappes on en
parle avec notre invité biga Ranx
Mandragora ou encore Raccoon la musique
reggae et électro va retentir à Voisins
le autonome ce week-end le festival la
tour mais les watts revient pour une
huitième édition une cinquième édition
on fait le point sur la programmation
dans cette émission et avec moi en
plateau des invités Christelle
évidemment bonsoir bonsoir alors demain
soir vous organisez une soirée
caritative pour aider les soignants à
des Yvelines au total une trentaine
d'oeuvre vont être mises en vente sur
art partage.com dont vous êtes la
présidente en un mot est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce qu'est art
partage.com en un mot alors il y aura
peut-être trois quatre mots mais sur les
pas de d'André Malraux et
démocratisation de l'accès à l'art et
donc on parlera de cette soirée
caritative que vous allez organiser
demain soir avec nous également sur ce
plateau Laurence Morel Losson bonsoir
alors vous êtes adjointe au
développement durable pour la mairie de
Villepreux à partir de samedi prochain
c'est la semaine du développement
durable dans votre ville à quoi faut-il
s'attendre cette année une très large
palette d'événements pédagogiques
culturel de ludique et cette fois-ci on
a choisi le thème de l'eau et du
changement climatique et donc on en
parlera plus en détail tout à l'heure
sur ce plateau nous sommes également
avec nous el Yakine Louise bonsoir alors
vous êtes responsable du secteur
improvisation pour Déclic Théâtre
vendredi début la 24e édition du cycle
mythe à la Meurice de Trappes alors pour
noter les spectateurs qui ne savent pas
le sigmit c'est le championnat
intercollège de match d'improvisation
théâtrale de 50 ans en Yvelines quel est
le niveau des collégiens cette année
un niveau disparaître tout au long de
l'année mais quand on arrive en
demi-finale c'est que voilà ça se
resserre donc
on va avoir un bon niveau en tout cas ça
va être une belle soirée comme on
organise depuis 24 ans maintenant
j'espère en tout cas et donc on fera le
point avec vous tout à l'heure plutôt
enfin d'émission avec nous également ce
soir en plateau Régine rage bonsoir
bonsoir vous allez nous présenter les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines ce sera dans quelques instants
mais avant je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin du soleil du soleil et
encore du soleil dans les Yvelines au
niveau des températures il fera bon
compter 16 degrés à Rambouillet et 17
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et
Versailles dans l'après-midi le beau
temps sera toujours au rendez-vous côté
température il fera en moyenne 26 à 27
degrés et demain nous fêterons la saint
Justin et du coup les saintes Justine
également le point maintenant sur les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Régina on
commence ces informations du jour par du
sport et plus particulièrement par Dieu
rugby et oui on va parler de rugby
d'ailleurs la Coupe du monde approche à
grands pas on est plus exactement à 100
jours de l'événement et pour marquer le
coup le comité d'organisation a présenté
aujourd'hui les médailles d'or d'argent
et de bronze de la compétition au siège
du Conseil régional d'Île-de-France
alors leur particularité à ces médailles
c'est qu'elles sont fabriquées à partir
de téléphone recyclés et la petite
parenthèse c'est que plus de 2006
téléphones ont été collectés et il est
nécessaire d'avoir 138 téléphones pour
fabriquer une selle médaille ah oui
quand même ouais tout à fait c'est assez
impressionnant alors juste pour revenir
sur l'événement donc des présidents de
clubs du rugby yvinois étaient présents
les Yvelines qui seront d'ailleurs terre
d'accueil de deux pays qui vont jouer à
la Coupe du Monde Versailles sera le
camp de base du Pays de Galles et
Croatie sur scène accueillera les de ton
gars et à ce propos je vous propose
d'écouter Valérie Pécresse président de
la Région Île-de-France pour moi le
sport d'une manière générale et le rugby
en particulier
ça unit les franciliens et cette coupe
du monde elle va être un grand moment de
cohésion l'Île-de-France va accueillir
une dizaine de matchs donc on va être
vraiment le centre de cette coupe du
monde et on veut en profiter évidemment
pour accueillir le monde l'accueillir
dignement montrer le sens de
l'hospitalité des franciliens et puis on
espère aussi qu'on va la gagner donc du
coup on est très fier on accueillera
trois équipes vous le savez l'équipe de
France à Rueil-Malmaison le Pays de
Galles l'équipe Tonga donc ça va être ça
va être un moment où toute
l'Île-de-France va se mettre à l'heure
du rugby c'est pour ça que nous avons
acheté 5000 places 5000 places pour les
jeunes franciliens premier inscrit
premier servi ce sera sur la base la
base c'est la plateforme la nouvelle
plateforme où il y aura tous les bons
plans pour les jeunes franciliens et
elle ouvrira le 23 juin prochain
et on continue avec du sport régime mais
cette fois ci on parle de tennis on va
revenir sur les résultats de tennis à
Roland-Garros hier après plus de trois
heures de jeu Richard Gasquet a cédé à
Arthur rintercnech alors lors du premier
tour à Roland-Garros le tennisman
originaire de Saint-Germain en l'aile à
emporter en quatre recettes donc 6 4 2 6
6 2 7 6 sur le cours Suzanne Lenglen et
demain lors du deuxième tour il sera
opposé à l'Américain Tyler fried et
concernant le plateau féminin alors sur
le plateau féminin on a également un
Caroline Garcia qui est aussi originaire
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye alors pour elle
malheureusement ce sera une défaite la
Russe Anna blinkova l'a battu en trois
sets donc 4 6 6 4 et 7,5 et aujourd'hui
mercredi 31 mai c'est aussi la Journée
mondiale sans tabac tout à fait Mathilde
comme chaque année depuis 1987 l'OMS
donc l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
organise de sensibilisation pour faire
connaître les dangers du tabac alors
malgré une baisse constante du nombre de
fumeurs depuis 2012 15 personnes meurent
chaque minute du tabac dans le monde et
on est justement on est allé interroger
des 5 continents aujourd'hui on leur a
demandé des conseils et des astuces pour
arrêter de fumer je vous propose de les
écouter
toutes les techniques toute la tactique
pour essayer de réduire déjà faut
réduire doucement mais sûrement avec la
cigarette électronique c'est un peu con
mais pile confinement aussi en fait
j'étais un peu
on va dire
enfin il y avait plus de sortie et tout
c'était plus calme du coup bah je me
suis dit que c'est le moment et je
passais à la clope électronique en
diminuant au fur et à mesure mon dosage
de nicotine j'ai une fille d'une amie je
l'ai conseillée c'est que je lui dis il
faut enlever une cigarette
par semaine faut l'oublier après pas une
et après la demi-heure et c'est comme ça
qu'elle a fait son ouvrage on arrivera
jamais à force quelqu'un arrêtait de
fumer s'il a envie n'est pas là parce
que moi longtemps j'ai eu envie
d'arrêter mais je l'ai pas fait
et cette année l'OMS a décidé
d'encourager les gouvernements à mettre
fin subventions accordé à la culture du
tabac et inciter les agriculteurs à
investir dans des cultures durables pour
améliorer la sécurité alimentaire et
aussi pour lutter contre la fin dans le
monde est-ce que vous avez des astuces
autour de ce plateau pour éviter de
arrêter de fumer
non non pas directement mais après je
trouve que ça c'est une bonne astuce si
les grands groupes déjà arrêté de nous
en proposer peut-être que ça serait plus
facile mais ouais bah c'est un fléau de
toute façon donc
en tout cas je sais que c'est difficile
mais retirer une cigarette par semaine
aussi ça peut être une astuce oui c'est
vrai arrêtez progressivement avec 5
cigarettes dans son paquet et la semaine
d'après en avoir quatre mais en fait on
part toujours avec son paquet en fait
on continue ces informations du jour
Régine des collégiens Yves Linois ont
remporté un concours pour promouvoir les
mathématiques auprès des jeunes
exactement et c'est le CNRS donc le
Centre National de Recherche
scientifique qui a lancé un concours
intitulé vidéo maths le but c'est de
réaliser une vidéo courte de 3 minutes
pour faire tomber les clichés autour des
mathématiques près de 2000 collégiens et
lycéens ont participé à cette coupe à
cette compétition alors pour cette
édition 2023 les élèves de l'école les
trois moulins situés à Bonnelles ont
reporté le premier prix dans la
catégorie collège il devait expliquer la
différence mathématique entre une boule
et une sphère alors je vous propose de
regarder un extrait alors diamètre de
7,5 cm donc rayon de 3,64 cm on peut
donc calculer notre volume 4/3
au cube ce qui me donne 220 cm3 dans le
cours de physique nous avons vu que la
masse volumique de l'acide oxydable
était de 7,5 g par centimètre cube et on
termine avec le chiffre du jour Régine
c'est 19100 pourquoi alors
19100 euros c'est le montant récolté à
l'occasion du Tea break Roland-Garros
donc l'événement caricatif caritatif
organisé par Véronique Chaplin et son
association SOS gazelle fêtait la
semaine dernière son 32e anniversaire
une édition qui s'est déroulée au golf
Robert Hersant tout proche des Yvelines
au programme de la journée une
compétition de golf par des équipes en
présence de grands noms du sport et du
parrain du rendez-vous qui est
d'ailleurs le comédien Bruno Solo qui a
joué dans la caméra cachée alors les
19100 euros ont été récoltés lors de la
traditionnelle vente aux enchères
et été mis aux enchères notamment les
maillots des footballeurs français Karim
Benzema et Eduardo camavinga ou encore
des raquettes d'illustre joueur de
Roland-Garros alors cet argent va aider
à financer les actions de l'association
SOS gazelles et va justement emmener des
enfants à défavoriser des Yvelines pour
un séjour en Bretagne pour les estivale
sport santé merci beaucoup Régine rallès
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager en utilisant le hashtag
[Musique]
une soirée caritative pour aider les
soignants des Yvelines c'est une
initiative d'art partage on en parlait
en début d'émission au total une
trentaine d'oeuvre sont en vente sur
Internet pour venir en aide aux
soignants chroniques des jours de
covid-19 days c'est le titre de cette
collection Christelle évidemment vous
êtes à l'initiative de ce projet comment
est-ce que ça a émergé d'où vous aimez
on était tous chez nous à cause de la
covid et deux artistes se sont
rencontrés sur la toile Emma Mao les et
Emmanuel de scoorail Maul qui est une
artiste peintre anglaise et Emmanuel de
SCO rail qui est écrivain par son de là
il y a eu le Queens le Queens a speech
je sais pas si je peux voilà le Queens
Spitz je le montre à l'écran je sais pas
par
voilà en fait c'est le démarrage de la
chronique c'est à dire que le discours
de la reine d'Angleterre a fait que emma
a peint la reine d'Angleterre ce
discours Emmanuel de scora il y a écrit
ils ont publié sur la toile et là
voilà ça a été un déferlement on veut
l'acheter on veut et ils ont pas ils
sont dit mais si les gens ont cette
réaction ça veut dire que il y a quelque
chose à et donc ils ont continué en
chroniquant tous les métiers qui étaient
à l'arrêt c'est à dire tous les gens et
il y a des gens connus pas connus et la
jeune fille la première jeune fille qui
est décédée de la covid Julie donc ils
ont fait c'est une succession de
portraits avec une bienveillance de de
on va dire alors on peut nous dire les
portraits sont prismes en 2020 faut la
remettre aussi en 2020 je pense que les
soignants avant 2020 ils étaient pas
bien 2020 ça a été pire que tout parce
qu'ils ont été sur le pont et que
maintenant
ça reste toujours pas facile donc
moi je les ai quand ils ont voilà ils
ont chroniqué toute cette qui est une
seule une seule chronique en France ce
projet il est unique et ça c'est encore
jamais fait et moi je suis arrivé par là
et avec avec un reportage.com mettez de
l'art dans les affaires puisque
je travaille avec les entreprises mais
également sur des projets qui font sens
et pour moi ça faisait sens à l'époque
j'ai contacté l'association solidarité
avec les soignants puisqu'elle s'est
créée à ce moment-là
et puis le fond de dotation l'esprit
colibri qui amène à cette soirée et on
leur disant en disant aux artistes mais
on a 30 oeuvre il faut absolument alors
moi j'allais très très loin et c'est
l'objectif de cette soirée c'est à dire
que pour moi on parle des soignants et
et c'est pour les soignants c'est à dire
que très très tôt au moment de la covid
on a parlé de bien il faut il faut
qu'ils aient des espaces et c'est ce que
fait l'association de solidarité avec
les soignants des espaces avec de
bien-être de détente pour eux mais qui
soit aménagé avec une bonne table avec
et moi je me suis dit bah là aussi ça
sert à ça c'est ce qui leur faut
aujourd'hui ça sert et alors comment
est-ce qu'on fait si on veut participer
à ce projet si on veut acheter une
oeuvre comment ça se passe
alors
très bonne question parce que il y a des
gens qui ne peuvent pas être là alors il
y a un Google forms sur que j'ai fait
par C sur les réseaux sociaux ou ce
Google form c'était pour inviter les
gens à participer puisque une entreprise
va bénéficier d'un mécénat d'un on va
dire d'une défiscalisation mais un
mécène privé qui ne veut absolument pas
voilà être qui veut être anonyme peut
aussi à particulier donc j'ai diffusé
cette information sur la toile par un
Google form pour l'invitation à cette
soirée que l'on fait demain dans
l'hôpital de Poissy et en parallèle j'ai
également des documents sur le drive que
je fais passer aussi en réseau où là les
gens ils peuvent complètement réserver
en disant mais moi ça m'intéresse je
vais voir le catalogue tout est en ligne
en fait donc par des outils sur une
technologie qui est super aussi
aujourd'hui même si je communique
beaucoup dans il faut être sur le
terrain mais on va dire que la technique
elle sert à ça et ce qui permet de voir
le catalogue de voir les prix d'avoir la
transparence aussi du modèle parce que
quand on est sur un Messenger moi je
suis une entreprise qui va qui agit pour
des associations et pour des donc il
faut que ce soit très clair pour tout le
monde ça c'est hyper important donc tout
est en ligne la clarté elle est
justement est-ce que ça vous intéresse
autour du plateau qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette initiative
vous avez raison tout ce qui peut être
fait pour voilà venir en soutien à nos
soignants vous avez raison aussi de
revenir sur l'ambiance parce qu'on a un
petit peu oublié je pense et on a juste
raison je pense qu'on a eu tous eu envie
de d'oublier de passer à autre chose
mais c'est vrai que comment dire c'est
c'est quand même une espèce de vision de
l'enfer quoi qui aurait imaginé que le
monde entier allait être bloqué comme ça
et les soignants ont vraiment eu des
mois
terribles et tout reposer sur eux donc
j'irai voir moi ça m'intéresse vraiment
quelque chose de beau aussi et je lis en
fait je sais pas qui va acheter ça si
c'est si c'est du des des
ou quoi qu'on peut revoir en
consultation
en fait je sais peut-être que j'aurais
pas les moyens
mais en tout cas ça peut être
intéressant de de me dire ah tiens bah
cette œuvre là je l'ai je l'ai déjà vu
dans le catalogue ne serait-ce que si
intéressé là il a redécouvrir et faire
effectivement de cette période qui a été
un peu sombre pour beaucoup
quelque chose de positif par ce biais là
et par là en tout cas je trouve ça super
c'est vrai que vous parliez de près on
l'a voulu en tout l'ensemble des œuvres
représente les 30 œuvres 20.000 euros
qui va être du don puisque les tous mes
scènes va acheter c'est entre 300 le
premier prix et et 1000 euros vous voyez
on est on reste dans quelque chose qui
est enfin on va dire accessible disons
on l'a on a on a voulu aussi mais parce
que c'est un plaisir mais le fait qu'il
achète le le mécène en achetant des
fiscalise et redonne pourquoi il
défiscalise parce qu'il va faire le don
de cette œuvre au fond de dotation
l'esprit colibri en plus de ça impulsion
peut-être que genre c'était la prochaine
question que vous vouliez me poser mais
rapidement parce qu'on est déjà un petit
peu pressé par le temps mais parce qu'il
y a il y a un reversement également
parce que je suis mandaté par les
artistes il y a un reversement en
numéraire pour le fond de dotation et
pour l'association solidarité avec les
soignants bien merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir accepté
elle me porte tous les projets sont
alors si vous êtes intéressés en tout
cas la soirée aura que demain soir de
18h30 à 21h30 à l'hôpital de Poissy une
partie des fonds récoltés reviendront au
groupement hospitalier des Yvelines Nord
et à l'association solidarité avec les
soignants créés par Anne Roumanoff un
chef Papou à la rencontre des lycéens de
Villeroy à Guyancourt le chef de la
tribu des Ulis mundaya kepanga a
présenté son film frère des arbres une
alerte sur la déforestation en Papouasie
Nouvelle-Guinée Nicolas dandry était sur
place écoutée
un chef Papou au lycée de Villaroy de
Guyancourt moundia kepanga et le chef de
la tribu des Ully un peuple situé sur
l'île de Papouasie Nouvelle-Guinée au
nord de l'Australie habitué aux
rencontres avec des jeunes occidentaux
son film frère des arbres réalisés avec
Marc d'osier veut sensibiliser à la
protection de l'environnement il était
super bien fait il était très touchant
ça nous montre la réalité qu'on nous
explique mais qu'on ne voit pas
forcément donc ça ça aide à mettre des
images sur des mots voir si des forêts
primaires qui disaient que ça a rédigé
beaucoup forcément ça fait un peu peur
mais je sais que il y a beaucoup de
solutions qui vont être mises en place
et j'espère que ça pourra s'améliorer on
sait tous que c'est très important c'est
tout ce qu'on doit faire entre
guillemets mais pas comme on l'a dit
dans le film pas grand bas et pas grand
monde qui fait quelque chose donc c'est
vrai que ça peut nous aider à nous
mobiliser ou quoi que ça donc c'est bien
après avoir regardé le film les lycéens
Guyancourtois ont pu échanger avec le
chef Papou un échange culturel entre la
France et la Papouasie Guinée et un
objectif précis pour moundia kepanga
avec les élèves étaient très importantes
parce que dans ma tribu on considère que
lorsqu'on veut plante une plante ou un
arbre il faut lui donner de l'eau pour
qu'il pousse bien mais c'est la même
chose avec les élèves et ils sont comme
des graines à qui on donne des conseils
exactement comme de l'eau et pour moi
rencontrer les élèves aujourd'hui c'est
partager avec eux mon expérience autour
de la protection de la nature et de
l'environnement mundiya kepanga voyage
depuis 2003 à travers le monde pour
alerter sur la déforestation dans son
pays il a déjà co-réalisé quatre films
le prochain documentaire baptisé gardien
de la forêt le temps des solutions est
en cours de production
[Musique]
lorsque tous les arbres auront disparus
les hommes disparaîtront à leur tour
[Musique]
allez de retour dans les Yvelines
direction Villepreux la Ville lance sa
Semaine du développement durable pour en
parler avec nous Laurence Morel Losson
vous êtes adjointe au développement
durable pour la ville cette année vous
avez choisi le thème de l'eau vous nous
en parler en début d'émission l'eau
c'est la vie c'est le thème pourquoi
alors en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'à Villepreux nous sommes on va dire
connus et reconnu depuis un certain
nombre d'années pour nos engagements en
matière de développement durable donc
nous organisons une semaine du
développement durable déjà depuis
plusieurs années en essayant à chaque
fois de balayer les fameux 17 objectifs
de développement durable vous savez tel
qu'ils ont été mises en place par les
Nations Unies mais cette année c'est
vrai qu'on a choisi ce thème de l'eau et
du changement climatique parce qu'on
souhaitait vraiment mettre le focus sur
ce thème voilà qui est on ne peut plus
crucial et pour nous cette semaine du
développement durable est vraiment là
pour sensibiliser en fait les familles
les riverains et donc choisir ce c'est
vraiment inviter les gens à se mobiliser
et donc on leur propose toute une série
de d'événements en fait il y a un peu
des choses proposées chaque jour tantôt
sous une forme plus
comment dire conférence scientifique des
choses vraiment destinées plus aux
adultes tantôt ce sont des propositions
plus ludiques pour pour les familles les
enfants mais on essaye de balayer voilà
un spectre large de manière à
séduire un peu tout le monde séduire
convaincre mobiliser enfin voilà alors
est-ce que ce thème de l'eau il est
aussi en lien avec ce que le département
vit on est en sécheresse depuis cet
hiver ça inquiétant on est en état
d'alerte d'usage de l'eau est-ce que
tout ça est lié tout ça est lié
forcément après le choix du thème il a
été fait il y a il y a un an il y avait
pas encore l'arrêté préfectoral qui
aurait cru que quand on aurait un avis
de sécheresse en plein hiver je pense
que ni à Villepreux ni ailleurs on va
imaginer mais bon voilà c'était déjà
dans l'air du temps malheureusement donc
oui c'est mais ça ne donne que en plus
vous savez peut-être Villepreux est une
ville très agricole donc nos
agriculteurs sont très sensibilisés sur
ce sujet là donc ça ne donne que plus de
résonance clairement alors au niveau du
programme samedi matin il y aura
notamment une visite de la station
d'épuration à Villepreux qu'est-ce que
les villes proviens et les villes
proviennent pourront découvrir et bien
tout le cycle en fait c'est vrai qu'on
ne se rend pas bien compte de la manière
dont l'eau est filtré comment dire je
pense qu'il y a aussi de la part des
gestionnaires du site la volonté de
sensibiliser les gens sur un certain
nombre de déchets qui sont comment dire
jetés notamment les fameuses lingettes
beaucoup de familles utilisent les
lingettes vous savez pour désinfecter la
salle de bain et c'est vraiment une
plaie pour pour les filtres des des
stations d'épuration c'est donc en fait
le but c'est vraiment de leur montrer
tout le cycle de l'eau et cette station
de de Chavenay Villepreux et de taille
réduite donc finalement on a vraiment
une vision assez claire du process donc
ça c'est ça c'est bien ensuite on a
différentes autres propositions
le dimanche on a une visite sur un axe
plus historique en fait on a souhaité
mettre un focus sur les usages de l'eau
mais au fil des décennies et des siècles
passés donc c'est assez donc on se
baladera à la découverte de citoyens des
lavoirs un moulin à eau qui faisait
fonctionner une manufacture de papier et
qui l'eût cru nous avons eu fin 19ème
une centrale hydroélectrique
au bord du rude Galli voilà c'est ce qui
a permis à Villepreux avant la guerre de
d'avoir chaque foyer connecté à
l'électricité donc voilà c'est c'est des
aspects voilà vous parliez des lingettes
tout à l'heure quels sont les les
usages les bons usages les bonnes
pratiques pour économiser l'eau
aujourd'hui alors ça on a aussi comment
dire des moments qui seront proposés aux
villes pour voilà faire prendre
conscience de ces bonnes pratiques avec
des stands des animations notamment le
samedi
ou 11 les bonnes pratiques voilà c'est
le 10 absolument 11 c'est le dimanche
alors on va notamment proposer un
atelier pour fabriquer comment dire avec
des pots en terre cuite des Zoya je ne
sais pas si vous connaissez les autres
ce terme c'est un système qui était
utilisé déjà dans l'Antiquité à l'époque
c'était des sortes d'enfants en terre
cuite non vernisées c'est très important
et ils étaient mises dans le sous-sol et
par capillarité en fait l'amphore est
rempli d'eau et par capillarité donc
elle elle diffuse autour d'elle de l'eau
mais vraiment avec parcimonie et ça
permet aux plantations autour de l'oya
ou d'avoir de l'eau en permanence sans
du coup pâtir de de la déshydratation
due au rayonnement solaire donc ça c'est
une chose qu'on va proposer nous allons
aussi proposer des permanences dans
notre maison des services publics avec
une les services de France Renov qui
viennent pour voilà conseiller les
riverains qui le souhaitent comment dire
dans leur travaux de rénovation ou voire
même d'installation de récupérateur
d'eau il y a des systèmes de subventions
et tout ça
voilà il y a différents ateliers et
moments où les villes provient pourront
avoir des conseils à ce sujet après il y
a aussi pas le cacher des comment dire
des moments qui seront clairement
ludiques toujours avec une un volet
pédagogique mais ludique on un jeu de
piste on aura des animations pour pour
les enfants
voilà bien merci beaucoup Laurence Morel
Losson d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors je le rappelle la semaine du
développement durable à Villepreux ça
débute ce samedi 3 juin et ça se déroule
jusqu'au 10 juin vous retrouverez toutes
les activités et le programme sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran et surtout si je peux dire
il y a quelques activités qui
nécessitent une inscription au préalable
en ligne notamment avec les associations
qui sont nos partenaires donc c'est
important donc important de le faire
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS direction
Versailles à présent c'est le retour du
Mois Molière dans la ville royale
spectacle musique danse cirque
investissent les rues les parcs les
jardins et les quartiers de la ville la
programmation est toujours aussi riche
on fait le point avec François demazir
le maire de Versailles et également le
créateur du mamolière
aujourd'hui je me trouve à Versailles
dans quelques jours se déroule le Mois
Molière le top départ c'est jeudi 1er
juin à la grande écurie du château de
Versailles le Mois Molière c'est le
rendez-vous culturel phare de l'été pour
en parler nous sommes avec François
demazieres bonjour alors vous êtes le
maire de Versailles mais également le
créateur du Mois Molière première
question cette année combien il y aura
de représentations durant tout le mois à
Versailles c'est difficile de vous
recommande précisément c'est le moins
Molière c'est devenu un très gros
festival sans doute après le festival
d'Avignon incomparable parce que c'est
vraiment la grande rencontre
quasimentale du théâtre le Mois Molière
doit se situer très dans les tous plus
gros festival après celui-ci il y aura
je pense dans la programmation
officielle il y a beaucoup de création
ce qui est important et dans la
programmation dit amateur là le nombre
des spectacles également fort
autour de 300 350 spectacles et alors
ces spectacles investissent des lieux
phares comme la grande écurie du château
mais aussi des lieux un peu plus
insolites les parcs les rues les
spectacles sont au sein des quartiers
c'est ça qui fait aussi la beauté de cet
événement oui le principe si vous voulez
c'est vraiment la culture qui va vers
tout le monde donc ça a été l'origine de
ce qu'on a voulu ce que j'ai voulu quand
j'ai créé ce festival c'était qu'on
aille facilement qui est pas la barrière
de l'argent notamment donc les
spectacles sont dans les quartiers et la
tradition de la Comédia del arte aussi
la comédie late qui a inspiré finalement
le théâtre de Molière et nous avons ici
l'Académie Internationale du théâtre
dirigé par Carnot Bozo a beaucoup de
troubles donc souvent ce sont ces
troubles qui vont dans les quartiers et
puis comme vous le disiez il y a des
lieux phares notamment la cour arrière
des grandes écuries de Château de
Versailles qu'un très beau lieu
qui est très simple c'est un mur
historique et cette cour a une belle
sonorité on met en face un gradin de 640
places cette année gradins est neuf je
le dis à tous les habitudes du Mois
Molière ils vont boire une
transformation les assises sont plus
agréables et donc une succession de
spectacles va se dérouler à l'intérieur
et puis vous avez évidemment d'autres
lieux vous pensez à toute la
programmation musicale c'est un festival
non seulement de théâtre mais aussi une
musique et la musique elle est partout
elle est aussi dans les églises car il y
a beaucoup de chorales de très grande
qualité à Versailles elle est au
Conservatoire de Versailles elle est
également dans des salles privées de
théâtre etc etc
[Musique]
et alors quelle est la ligne conductrice
de cette année de cette édition 2023
c'est des spectacles de création de
compagnie des gens reconnus si vous
voulez qui vont aller ensuite à Avignon
présenter leur spectacle ces spectacles
sont vendus à Avignon et ensuite il
tourne dans toute la France j'aime
l'esprit de troupes donc c'est ça que
l'on met en avant mais c'est il y a
quelques solos c'est la mode aujourd'hui
pendant les enfants financières il y a
beaucoup plus de spectacles qui sont des
waman shoes c'est pas tellement ce que
j'essaye de mettre en avant sauf le
spectacle en particulier c'est plutôt au
contraire spectacle où vous avez
vraiment l'esprit du théâtre avec des
troupes Éric Bouvron qui fera
l'ouverture et quelqu'un qui fait ses
créations ici justement on va parler de
l'ouverture de cette 27e édition
braconnier ce sera aux grandes écuries
est-ce que que nous en parler un petit
peu plus de ce spectacle de cette pièce
oui alors toutes les créations sont
intéressantes honnêtement et
braconnier je l'ai mis en ouverture
parce que effectivement on a une sorte
de fidélité avec certains metteurs c'est
le cas avec Eric avec Bouvron
eric a un cursus personnel assez
passionnant c'était qu'il est par son
père il est sud-africain par sa mère il
est grecque et en fait il travaille en
français depuis des années et il a
développé une écriture très inspirée
d'ailleurs des canevas américains donc
c'est ce sont des histoires mais aussi
avec cette capacité qu'il a connaissant
bien les cultures du monde et bien
d'amener des musiques qu'on entend
rarement en France et ça donne des
univers et il a eu pour les cavaliers
qui sait qu'il a monté il y a maintenant
quatre ans le Molière du meilleur
spectacle de théâtre privé ce qui est
vraiment la plus haute qu'on pense des
Molières dans le privé il y a aussi un
spectacle public mais là on est dans des
créations privées et alors quelle
seconde les autres grands rendez-vous de
cette édition pour moi parce que je vais
vous dire dans le programmateur je peux
vous dire que tout est intéressant mais
quand vous faites des créations ce qui
est important de dire ici c'est que
c'est une chance pour les spectateurs
c'est qu'ils vont voir vraiment des
premières c'est des spectacles qui
seront donnés pour la première fois
et qui vont ensuite avoir leur carrière
pendant si ça marche bien plusieurs
années et donc là sur les 13 créations
il y en a plusieurs et ça je peux le
noter comme une caractéristique qui
touche autour de thématique de la guerre
pas de façon traitée de façon un peu
noire sinistre mais plutôt au contraire
toujours avec un peu de distance et il y
a des créations très attendues comme
notamment un spectacle avec un metteur
en scène qui est très très reconnu qui
crée sur le thème à rentrer
42 entre 40 ans et la rentrée scolaire
42 dans certains quartiers de Paris
notamment le 11e arrondissement et bien
trois quarts des invités pas là parce
que tout simplement c'était suite à la
race du Vél' d'hier et ses enfants
n'étaient plus là
nous avons beaucoup d'étrangers
grimpèrent zuloski Cohen c'est quand
même un poids mort dans une classe et
bien mesdames
alors
madame la Directrice non mais c'est
incroyable c'est un censé nous sommes en
guerre Madame la Directrice toutes les
possibles tous les accents sont des
petits ou pas du quartier et attendez
c'est pas fini ouais
je continue pourquoi tout de suite
parler de rafle et d'abord quelle race
quelle preuve avez-vous
c'est comme un
océan
mais en continuant à enseigner nous
résistons au pouvoir tous les opposants
au régime sont arrêtés rejoins-nous
Gisèle
c'est deux octobre 1942 fera date dans
les annales de l'éducation nationale
petite fille de l'école Victor Hugo
n'arriveront jamais jamais
[Musique]
mais vous avez d'autres spectacles je
pourrais vous citer la même façon de le
reste Dolorès un spectacle sur des
tensions de tango là aussi on est en
rapport avec l'histoire de la guerre
parce que c'était un frère ou une sœur
c'est une histoire vraie c'est un vrai
un seul qui était des danseurs de tango
très saine des années 30 elle va
disparaître elle va être tuée en fait
par les nazis si vous voulez et lui va
continuer tout seul et continuons en
souvenir de sa seuil il va se
transformer il va danser comme une femme
en fait si vous voulez c'est une soirée
et bien merci beaucoup François
Demazières d'avoir accepté de répondre à
nos questions le mot Molière ça commence
le 1er juin et ça se termine le 2
juillet aux grandes écuries avec la
représentation de la pièce Le Médecin
malgré lui vous retrouverez toute la
programmation sur le site internet moi
molière.com
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par Pierre Michel Planchon bonsoir alors
dans quelques instants on parlera avec
vous du festival de musique Latour mais
les wattes à Voisins le bretonneux mais
avant petit tour de plateau quel est
votre pièce de Molière préférée
imaginaires moi par rapport à
l'improvisation théâtrale c'est
l'impromptitude Versailles
c'est une pièce où il travaille un cocus
en fait où on voit les comédiens au
travail pour présenter une pièce
improvisée au roi et parce que il y a
une commande un peu un peu prompte comme
ça faut savoir que Molière a jamais
écrit ces textes lui-même on parle de la
langue de Molière mais c'est quelque
chose Molière a toujours fait improviser
ces comédiens sur des trams et les
textes sont arrivés plus tard bah pour
vendre en fait du texte donc je pourrais
pas le situer dans le temps je suis
passé mais je sais que rarement les
textes de Molière ont été écrits par
Molière
Christelle évidemment votre pièce
préférée classique les Fourberies de
Scapin
et vous passerez donc
un classique aussi
vous parlez d'improvisation on continue
on va parler du sick meat vendredi
débute le championnat inter collège de
match d'improvisation théâtrale organisé
par Déclic Théâtre l'événement aurait
lieu à la Merise de Trappes pour en
parler avec nous nous el Yakine Louise
vous êtes le responsable du secteur
improvisation de Déclic Théâtre
l'association organisatrice de cet
événement alors sur les 14 collèges de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il n'en reste
plus que 4 en demi-finale la mare au sol
de Coignières qui affrontera le collège
Philippe de Champaigne de la verrière et
Gustave Courbet à Trappes qui affrontera
Anatole France des Clayes-sous-Bois
c'est souvent les mêmes établissements
pas souvent les mêmes établissements qui
se retrouvent en demi-finale on a
l'impression que c'est quand même les
mêmes qui reviennent ouais déjà si je
peux me permettre de vous corriger nous
on dit pas qui affrontera on dit qu'il
rencontrera parce que en fait
l'affrontement dans le dans
l'improvisation dans le match
d'improvisation c'est quelque chose qui
est on n'a pas de fédération on a pas de
règlement inscrite pour tout le monde
mais on sait une chose en tant
qu'improvisateur c'est qu'on joue jamais
contre les autres moi j'ai toujours avec
les autres c'est c'est voilà pour le
pour le bonheur du sport après est-ce
que ce sont toujours les mêmes qui
reviennent ce que on a l'impression mais
en vrai sur des longues sur des longues
séquences s'échangeant donc
on peut revoir des collèges revenir mais
après c'est aussi ce qui se passe dans
les établissements les enfants qu'on
rencontre les bandes qui arrivent à se
former et à ce à se créer autour de
autour de cette pratique et comment ils
ont envie de briller mais elle a une
dernière là sur ces quatre là par
exemple je crois qu'on en avait que deux
l'année dernière la mare au sol est
Anatole France des Clayes-sous-Bois et
la mare au sol de Coignières on avait un
autre collège trappiste qui était le
village l'année dernière cette année
c'est courbé et l'année dernière on
avait les prix de Montigny donc ça
venait on a champagne du minime examin
non c'est c'est
tourne ça tourne sur du très long terme
ça tourne alors comment ça se
concrètement la soirée est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire un petit déroulement
alors la soirée espace bien déjà
ensuite espace en trois temps donc on a
deux demi-finales on a une première
demi-finale avec un lot de remerciement
parce qu'en fait c'est un travail sur
toute une saison on travaille sur 14
collèges à l'année donc on rencontre
beaucoup beaucoup de gens au-delà des
enfants et aussi tous les tous les
institutionnels des établissements nos
partenaires donc on fait un premier lieu
un premier lot de remerciement un peu
comme ça en pause
entre après la première demi-finale on a
une deuxième demi-finale donc qui se
joue
fait un lot de remerciements et de salut
à l'ensemble des gens qui nous ont aidé
à mettre les choses en place dans les
établissements et puis après et après
et puis déroule
78 pardon on sait pas comment ça se
déroule si je vais vous dire
en fait je sais bien non les matchs
d'improvisation on a on a on a deux
équipes du coup qui se présentent autour
d'une d'une patinoire qui signifie sur
scène et on a souvent donc l'arbitre je
sais pas si on voit mon petit tract
souvent c'est moi l'arbitre en tout cas
en l'occurrence là ça sera moi et donc
je donne un thème
aux deux équipes avec le temps que va
durer l'improvisation à éventuellement
un registre de jeu donc ça peut être à
la manière de Molière par exemple
et puis
en termes de contraintes le nombre de
joueurs et puis si les équipes ont joué
l'une après l'autre ou si elles vont
jouer ensemble
elles ont 20 secondes de concertation 20
30 secondes en tout cas le même temps de
concertation pour Line et l'autre équipe
et ensuite elle se rend compte dans la
patinoire pour développer une histoire
ensemble une histoire que personne ne
connaît ni elle ni public et l'histoire
se raconte
le titre comment ça comment vous faites
en tant qu'arbitre pour pour départager
les équipes c'est le public qui
départage des équipes dans un premier
temps le public a un carton de vote
bicolore et du coup à la fin de chaque
improvisation il va il va montrer son à
ma demande il va demander il va montrer
son carton avec la face visible pour le
sur la scène du de l'équipe qui leur a
préféré et donc on va compter les points
comme ça mais après il y a aussi des
fautes il y a des règles du jeu et c'est
là où ça devient hyper pédagogique est
hyper intéressant aussi pour pour les
enfants c'est que ben on peut les
pénaliser s'il se coupe la parole si une
équipe essaye d'enfoncer l'autre par des
vannes gratuites si voilà toutes ces
choses là sont sont pris en maîtrise par
l'arbitre et puis quand elles font trois
fautes elle donne un point à l'autre
équipe donc en fait du coup elle joue le
jeu elles font aussi attention de de pas
tomber voilà dans dans dans ces
erreurs est-ce qu'il y a des blagues des
situations qui marchent toujours auprès
du public alors il y en a qui marche
toujours mais comment ça marche toujours
ça veut dire que c'est de la triche très
chère parce que en fait si ça marche
toujours ça veut dire qu'on l'a déjà
fait et si on l'a déjà fait c'est plus
de l'improvisation donc c'est c'est ça
réchauffé en plus ça va être pas à la
création mais moi j'y vais au grain mais
des fois je passe des fois un petit peu
au travers parce que c'est vrai que
internet aujourd'hui avant on regardait
tous les mêmes programmes on savait tout
ce qui se passait aujourd'hui il y a
tellement de culture disponibles et puis
faut s'y intéresser aussi je veux dire à
ce que font les jeunes c'est vrai que
des fois je peux passer un petit peu à
l'AS sur des sur sur des blagues qui qui
ont pas inventé eux mais qui sont allés
chercher
ailleurs mais
après des choses qui ont existé qui se
rejouent oui il y en a et ça reste
valable dans la mesure où comme c'est
pas inscrit dans le marbre de toute
façon ça reste quelque chose qui se qui
va se développer autrement parce que
comme et puis on sait pas avec qui on
joue donc en fait on va se retrouver
avec quelqu'un qui va qui va qui va
répondre ailleurs et puis on va être
obligé de suivre ça alors que peut-être
on avait quelque chose de bien inscrit
qui nous emmenait là-bas mais on est
obligé d'écrire avec celui qui nous
accompagne
alors comment il se prépare justement
ces jeunes c'est quoi les gens voulaient
dire pourquoi c'est pas improviser le
match d'improvisation il faut prendre un
travail tout au long de l'année et ben
je vous le dire et c'est super important
merci de cette question
en fait on va travailler du on va
travailler beaucoup de jeux de reflexe
de prise de parole prise de parole
individuel en groupe de schéma narratif
ça ça peut faire partie des choses aussi
qu'on qu'on établit
et puis après ouais on va travailler sur
le groupe sur entre guillemets j'aime
bien dire la bande mais je sais que le
mot peut être péjoratif à des moments
donnés quand je dis la bande c'est à
dire qu'on s'entend bien on est bien
ensemble et on a envie de développer une
image collective des fins de son collège
aussi un moment donné représenter
quelque chose
donc on travaille on travaille sur tout
ça le coach le comédien qui va venir
dans l'établissement va rencontrer un
groupe de jeunes en début d'année au
mois d'octobre et puis tout doucement il
va se mêler un petit peu avec eux pour
essayer de ressortir effectivement le
meilleur de ce que vont pouvoir proposer
ces élèves là
ce qu'on travaille avant tout après on a
des objectifs ça c'est c'est largement
valable on va parler d'écoute de de
schéma narratif de construction
d'histoire mais après on peut aussi
toucher du doigt le personnage toucher
du doigt le timing le Tang va durer
l'improvisation pour bien terminer les
registres touchés du doigt la présence
au public comment le capter l'attention
du public
en théâtre avant de travailler le texte
et avant de travailler le texte il y a
mille choses qu'on peut travailler et
puis en plus nous on n'est pas juste
comédien quand on est improvisateur on
est auteur metteur en scène scénographe
comédien alors à notre niveau forcément
tout réduit sur des formats de 3 minutes
ou plus pour pour les meilleurs mais
quoi qu'il en soit on
doit être capable de d'avoir toutes ces
notions et de savoir en jouer en fait
pour pour donner le meilleur public
merci beaucoup
l'année dernière on avait organisé un
grand match d'improvisation dans le
cadre d'un championnat européen je crois
et moi qui me connaissais pas j'ai été
impressionnée par les rituels qu'il y a
dans l'improvisation avec beaucoup de
choses récurrentes le fait visiblement
il faut prendre l'habitude de huer
parfois
mais ça donne une ambiance mais de folie
comment dire j'encourage vraiment les
gens à assister parce que c'est c'est ça
vient du sport nord-américain qui avant
d'être du sport c'est déjà du spectacle
c'est c'est calqué sur des matchs de
calqué sur les matchs de hockey et et
les gens alors faut savoir qu'il y a une
grande culture de la profonde on sait
qu'il y a une grande culture du match
d'improvisation sur le sur le bassin 58
mois particulièrement attrape où on peut
dire que c'est là où où il y a eu le
gros focus et puis la tchatche mais du
coup les gens sont habitués donc il y a
une vraie
c'est du patrimoine en fait le
d'improvisation sans vouloir me placer
au dessus des autres mais en vrai il y a
des on arrive à des troisième
générations
d'improvisateur il y a des gens qui ont
leurs parents voir certains leur
grands-parents qui ont fait nos
improvisation de famille
si vous êtes intéressé la vente qui a
24e édition du site meet c'est vendredi
prochain à 20h30 à la Merise de Trappes
pour prendre vos billets rendez-vous sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran allez c'est l'heure à
présent du coup de coeur cinéma d'un
professionnel Yves Linois du 7e art
cette semaine c'est le réalisateur
Quentin Dupuis qui nous parle d'Alien un
film de science-fiction mais aussi
d'horreur regardez
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous présenter alien un film
de ridescott de 1979 écrit par Dano
banane donc alien c'est le deuxième film
de Ridley Scott après les dieux listes
alors faut savoir que Riley Scott par
contre avait eu toute une très grande
carrière dans la publicité avant donc il
arrivait sur le tard entre guillemets au
cinéma les devises d'ailleurs qui
étaient qui avaient été à Cannes mais
alien n'est que entre guillemets son
deuxième film beaucoup de choses ont été
dit aussi sur alien et sur tout le
sous-tex sexuel sur le viol sur la place
de la femme sur tout ça mais alien c'est
aussi finalement on le vend souvent
quand un film de science-fiction mais
surtout un film d'horreur dans l'espace
on voit que très peu le monstre et en
question il y a toute une atmosphère de
tension qui a créé tous les codes du
genre du film d'horreur sont là plus que
du film de SF alien finalement cette
histoire de routine de l'espace qui
prennent en stop une créature et
derrière tout va très très mal se passer
c'est un film qui est assez incroyable
parce qu'il était deux ans après Star
Wars et après du coup Star Wars tous les
studios sont dit ça y est la
science-fiction c'est génial c'est
redevenu un genre à entre guillemets un
genre acceptable et puis un sous genre
de cinéma si tant que qu'il y en ait et
donc du coup tout le monde tout le monde
voulait faire de la SF et ce scénario
est arrivé à la Fox avec Ridley Scott
donc en deuxième film et que finalement
il a fait l'anti Star Wars quelque part
alien c'est l'anti Star Wars c'est pas
du Space Opéra c'est gore ça fait peur
là où Star Wars dans une sur l'espoir
alien on est quand même sur l'opposé
c'est l'espace c'est l'endroit où il
faut pas mettre les pieds on n'est pas
fait pour aller dans l'espace et ce qui
fonctionne vraiment dans ce film c'est
ce côté très humain très terre à terre
ça pourrait se passer dans un setting
complètement différent la grande Ford
haleine évidemment les designs versus
Giger qui a créé l'alien et tous les
décors qui sont aussi aujourd'hui
emblématiques et qui restent une des
créatures les plus effrayantes de
l'histoire du cinéma
[Musique]
allez on va parler de musique à présent
vendredi et samedi prochain le festival
de musique Latour mais les watts revient
à Voisins le bretonneux pour en parler
avec nous Pierre Michel Le Planchon vous
êtes le coordinateur de metasos
l'association organisatrice de
l'événement alors vous avez plusieurs
têtes d'affiches cette année biga Ranx
Mandragora on en parle juste après mais
avant je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait
de toi parce qu'avec ta petite voix tes
petites manières
tu as percé sur ma de milliers
d'euros petite furie je me bats pour toi
pour que dans 10 millions de sang on se
retrouve à l'abri
sans assiette des milliards
[Musique]
les autres artistes de rayer cette année
qui va ouvrir le festival qui s'appelle
rojavi qu'on est extrêmement que heureux
d'accueillir on a la six artistes le
samedi donc rogerby on a deux Benco en
dans un style plus d'hub flox on a
également le Peuple de l'Herbe qui
revient cette année à ce qu'il devait
jouer l'année dernière mais
malheureusement on a eu des intempéries
donc on est content quand même de
pouvoir
jouer exactement
avec la semaine
voilà donc on a deux scènes en plein air
donc une qui est sur la cour de deux
covids la Voisins-le-Bretonneux et une
qui a le jardin Eugène fleuret qui est
juste à côté donc ça joue en alternance
et donc voilà six artistes par soir et
elle serait se rend rendez-vous donc ce
sera extrêmement festif joyeux et
convivial
alors en plus sur de l'électro de la
transe on aura notamment Mandragora la
tête d'affiche on écoute aussi un
extrait et on en parle juste après
[Musique]
alors on est dans une autre ambiance on
entend bien on est plus dans de la
transe ça se conjugue bien c'est de
styles musicaux donc dans un festival le
reggae et l'électro la France
on voulait vraiment développer cette
thématique sur la musique électronique
vraiment le vendredi parce que c'est
aussi une musique qui est de plus en
plus écoutée quand même à part des
jeunes et c'est aussi un public qu'on
essaye de viser mine de rien faire des
choses aussi pour la jeunesse et ça ça
nous semblait extrêmement important et
ça se marie bien ce qu'on est quand même
dans un côté assez festif alors c'est
vrai que du coup le samedi ce sera
certainement un peu plus familial et on
a souvent accueilli pas mal de familles
sur le festival et c'est quelque chose
on était surpris on va dire les
premières éditions au début et on en est
extrêmement content en fait voilà
au-delà de la musique ce contient aussi
à coeur dans ce festival c'est tout le
côté environnement et co-responsable
tout à fait alors ça date pas de d'hier
ça fait quand même pas mal d'années
parce que ce festival là il existe
depuis 1999 ce qui s'appelait la tour
prend l'air et c'est vrai que dans les
années 2005 à 2010 il y a tout de suite
eu des actions en fait de
sensibilisation et
voilà je vais te donner des exemples ça
va être assez parlant donc par exemple
des toilettes sèches ça ça a été mis en
place il y a très longtemps et c'est
vrai que ça se développe de plus en plus
c'est ça que nous c'est quelque chose
qui a été fait maintenant il y a plus de
15 ans et donc il y a quand même aussi
un accompagnement avec les festivaliers
expliqué comment ça fonctionne etc donc
il y a toutes sortes de choses le tri
sélectif également ça c'est un défi mais
chaque année on essaye vraiment
d'améliorer le tri alors c'est parfois
pas facile parce que quand on regarde
même comment ça se passe le tri selon
les communes sont les religions les
villes chacun a ses sont tirés les
cheveux et c'est vrai que parfois on
veut bien faire mais il y a des choses
toutes bêtes on se dit mais on en fait
quoi on sait pas comment où le gérer et
bon on essaye de s'améliorer d'année en
année donc on fait aussi attention à
l'eau
etc alors petit tour de plateau est-ce
que ça vous donne envie d'y aller oui je
dois dire que le mélange moi je connais
moins la musique trance mais je trouve
que le fait de mélanger comme ça du
reggae et de la musique plus
contemporaine et puis la façon dont vous
en parler ça donne très envie peut-être
le côté environnement
[Rires]
je connaissais l'artiste reggae là déjà
qui est passé et
mais je serai plus ceux de la soirée du
samedi moi plus que de la soirée
vendredi parce que je joue le vendredi
mais de toute façon mais je suis content
que ça revienne en tout cas sous une
autre forme la tour reprend l'air si je
peux l'appeler comme ça tout à fait
merci beaucoup en tout cas et vous
crystal évidemment pareil c'est toujours
la fuite découverte puis la musique ça
ça rassemble c'est chouette je vais dire
quelque soit après
donc forcément on a on va on partage pas
tous les styles de musique mais je
trouve que c'est bien c'est alors est-ce
qu'il reste des places plus réglé moi
[Rires]
alors est-ce qu'il reste des places pour
pouvoir y assister
là on regarde
un peu les ventes comment ça se passe
évidemment et cette année encore une
belle surprise par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est qu'on a vendu encore un
peu plus de place donc pour l'instant ça
s'annonce très bien à un super
remplissage donc on a d'accueillir le
public
qui va être nombreux donc ça ça va être
vraiment aussi une bonne gestion à faire
pour nous pour les équipes là ils sont
en train de tous se préparer à se dire
on va accueillir du monde donc
il reste des places après petit message
au téléspectateurs quand même ne tardez
pas trop on ne sait jamais et bien merci
beaucoup Pierre Michel Planchon d'avoir
répondu à donc si vous souhaitez vous
rendre au festival La Tour meliwatts
c'est ce vendredi 2 et samedi 3 juin à
l'espace de Coville de Voisins le
bretonneux les tarifs vont de 20 à 40
euros pour prendre votre place et sur le
site internet en bas de votre écran et
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
et demain matin nous aurons encore du
soleil dans les Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera bon conteste degré
à Rambouillet et 17 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles
dans l'après-midi le beau temps sera
toujours au rendez-vous côté température
il fera en moyenne 26 à 27 degrés et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]